There are multiple ways to do this, but here is the one I chose. I chose to
make one printf statement for each row. We want eight spaces with the number of
cookies, followed by a vertical bar. Followed by eighth spaces with the number
of boxes of cereal. Followed by another bar, followed by the name. I'll need to
print all three variables, so I'll include them as parameters separated by
commas. The format string will start with int value, so I'll use a d. And it'll
be eight wide, so I have 8. Then, that vertical bar, then the decimal value,
percent f with a width of 8 and 2 decimal places and then the string. The
formatting string will look the same for my row and for cay's row, but I'll use
cay's variables instead of mine. Since I'm using this pattern twice, maybe I
would want to make a variable for it. And call it, Row Pattern or something
like that, but since I'm only using it twice, I'm going to leave it for now. So
far it looks like I'm eating all of the cookies on my own. But I haven't
surveyed all of my coworkers yet, the answer could change. Now, if I'm going to
collect more data, I may want to change my program to use a scanner to take in
input and put it in the table. We'll leave that for now though.